from a messy behind-the-scenes romance
to a Twitter tirade that sank the entire
show the making of Roseanne was just as
chaotic as the lives of its on-screen
characters
getting Roseanne to the small screen
wasn't easy in the 1980s television
producers Marcy Carsey and Tom Werner
wanted to make a series about a working
mother they commissioned a script from
writer Matt Williams and thought that
Roseanne Barr's Domestic Goddess Persona
would be a perfect fit but bar and
Williams were combative from the start
Vanity Fair reported that Williams
wanted to call it life and stuff to keep
Barr from having too much control but
Barr wanted to Simply call it Roseanne
Barr got her title but it was just the
first in a series of battles between the
star and the writer you know I'd be
really good for breakfast what hi
tell them no no
while Williams is credited as the sole
creator of Roseanne Barr reportedly
wanted credit since she felt the show
was based on her life Williams car seat
and Werner claimed it was actually a
matter with the writer's Guild of
America mere weeks into production Barr
wanted Williams fired and threatened to
leave the show Williams did bow out but
not before taking a large Financial
settlement for his efforts
there was never any doubt that John
Goodman would play Dan Connor on
Roseanne before being cast Goodman had a
series of small roles in classic 80s
films like Revenge of the Nerds and
Raising Arizona but he was hardly a star
Warner claimed that they were looking
for an actor who could match bars
Charisma and Goodman nailed his screen
test however while ABC wanted Roseanne
to move quickly into production Goodman
had a scheduling conflict but Werner and
Casey were so confident of his talents
that they forfeited a coveted time slot
in order to keep Goodman in the role one
kid down two to go darling
in a career retrospective for Vanity
Fair Goodman recalled how he liked the
script and immediately hit it off with
Barr Goodman left his audition knowing
he had the job something that rarely
happened to him he found job security in
the role of Dan Connor playing the
character for years not only in Roseanne
but also its popular spin-off series The
Connors bar and Tom Arnold were long
time friends on the stand-up comedy
circuit before they fell in love while
taping Roseanne's 1987 HBO Comedy
Special the Roseanne Barr show while
Barr was married and Arnold was in a
relationship they soon were inseparable
Arnold became and was subsequently fired
from his gig as Roseanne's warm-up
comedian but he was eventually hired on
the show's writing staff after Barr's
insistence the pair married in 1990. in
addition to playing the character Arne
Thomas Arnold ascended to executive
producer on Roseanne and essentially
took control of Barr's career leading
bar to fire most of her team at the time
of their marriage A source told Vanity
Fair Roseanne is oblivious to everything
but Tom Arnold the couple brought their
outlandish Behavior to the set of
Roseanne even igniting rumors that they
were engaged in a three-way relationship
with their assistant turned executive
Kim Silva soon after in 1994 Barr and
Arnold's marriage ended and so did
Arnold's time on Roseanne Barr fired
Arnold and Silva and reportedly changed
the locks on their production office
Roseanne wasn't the only TV
collaboration between bar and Arnold the
pair produced multiple short-lived
sitcoms including the Jackie Thomas Show
and Tom in 1992 while Roseanne was the
number one show on television the Jackie
Thomas show was designed to be a vehicle
for Arnold making its debut that
December according to the New York Times
ABC was concerned about putting the
poorly tested show in the coveted and
highly lucrative time slot directly
after Roseanne the show had promising
debut ratings but its decline in
viewership left ABC hesitant to renew it
for another season that's when things
got ugly what happened well I'll tell
you what happened the big monkey ate the
little monkey
in 1993 Barr reportedly threatened to
take Roseanne to another Network in
retaliation for what she perceived to be
disrespect over the Jackie Thomas show
all the while sending scathing faxes to
negative critics while Arnold told the
press that Jackie Thomas was picked up
for a second season it was only a tactic
to bully ABC into renewing the show
ultimately Arnold left Jackie Thomas to
develop the sitcom Tom for CBS but this
new sitcom only had a short run in 1994
before being canceled the Roseanne
chicken shirt has become one of
television's most recognized pieces of
anti-fashion Barr wrote for vulture that
she clashed with the Wardrobe Department
early in the show's production so she
ended up wearing her own clothes on the
set after this dispute Roseanne's
wardrobe Department apparently developed
a sense of humor they introduced the
chicken shirt first worn by Lisi
goranson's Becky as a joke in season two
but once Marr saw the design its
ugliness became something of an artistic
statement the shirt went on to play
heavily in season 5's finale episode
daughters and other strangers it rotated
among cast members with numerous actors
sporting the Garment during the episode
the chicken shirt would live on as
Roseanne's apron design at her
restaurant the Lanford lunchbox it also
appears during season 10's opening
credits called incalculably ill-judged
by the Rotten Tomatoes critics consensus
strange scattered and self-conscious by
vulture and one of the war series
finales of all time by variety season 9
of Roseanne left long time fans confused
and even alienated when season 9 was
announced the New York Times reported
that both Barr and ABC decided it would
be the show's last breaking from the
show's working class family Strife the
final season saw the Connors win 108
million dollars in the lottery the
season bounced between wish fulfillment
stories and self-referential television
parodies with John Goodman's Dan Connor
notably absent from most of the season's
episodes this was due to Goodman walking
away from Roseanne because he was
reportedly fed up with the onset drama
the Roseanne finale when the entire
Lottery premise is revealed to be
Roseanne's fantasy after Dan had passed
away remains controversial to this day
got you some notepads and I got you a
dictionary a thesaurus
you know Stephen King started this way
even though season 9 was billed as the
show's swan song There were talks of a
Roseanne spin-off series the Los Angeles
Times claimed the show would have seen
Roseanne and Michael Fishman's DJ moving
to Las Vegas with ABC balking at the
show's high price the idea didn't stick
an unlikely meeting of Comedy Divas
happened during season 9's Halloween
episode Satan darling when Roseanne
crossed over with the UK comedy
sensation absolutely fabulous in the
episode newly minted millionaire
Roseanne and her sister Jackie attended
a party in New York City where she meets
London Fashion maven's Patsy and Idina
played by Joanna Lumley and Jennifer
Saunders respectively the foursome drink
excessively and the episode transitions
into a parody of the 1968 horror film
Rosemary's Baby Roseanne's connection to
absolutely fabulous is not entirely
inorganic in 1995 the New York Times
reported that Barr purchased the rights
to produce an American version of the
BBC series the project was a hot
commodity in Hollywood but abfab never
got off the ground instead Barr and
Saunders collaborated on Satan darling
with Saunders later recounting it was
very bizarre we were quite confused but
it was fun while Barr is revered as a
trailblazing female Talent bucking the
system of Hollywood she's also known for
being a difficult Boss Bar admitted to
ABC news that she made a list of people
whom she'd fire when the show reached
number one in the ratings and she
eventually followed through Roseanne
writer and executive producer Bruce
Halford was warned by his agent and
lawyer that Barr fires everyone after
one year sure enough he was eventually
canned even future television Powerhouse
Chuck Laurie was the focus of Barr's ire
he told the television Academy that he
was almost fired because she hated his
first script writers on Roseanne
recalled to ew how Barr dehumanized them
by referring to them by numbers instead
of names bar on the other hand claimed
that the practice stripped the writers
of their self-entitlement and that they
learned something from the practice
while some writers clashed with her
abrasive management Barr credits herself
for championing female writers and
giving then unknown talents like Joss
Whedon and Judd Apatow their first
writing gigs Lisa gorinson and Sarah
chalk both played the Conor's eldest
daughter Becky gorinson originated the
character playing her for the Show's
first five seasons however the role was
recast when gordonson decided to attend
college according to ew after testing
hundreds of actors for the role chalk
was cast while chalk was around for part
of season 6 and all of season 7 gorinson
was able to mix her higher education
Pursuits with her sitcom stardom she
returned to Roseanne for parts of season
8 sharing the role with chalk though
chalk was the show's Soul Becky for
season 9. the humor of having two actors
play the same character sometimes in the
same season was not lost on Roseanne the
show included self-aware jokes about
Goranson and chalk playing the same role
including a parody of The Patty Duke
Show theme song in season 8. when
Roseanne returned for season 10 in 2018
both Goranson and chalk came back to the
show a new role was created for chalk
and for the first time both actors
shared the screen
before Roseanne Halloween themed Network
television episodes were few and far
between the show arguably contributed to
the invention of dedicated spooky season
episodes Roseanne Barr told Yahoo
entertainment that ABC initially
resisted making Roseanne Halloween
episodes fearing it would alienate part
of Their audience however Barr argued
that Halloween was popular and after she
won the debate she called the victory
quote the first dragon we slayed on the
Roseanne show with the network green
lighting the concept the Beloved
tradition was born in season 2's episode
boo where the Conor stage a haunted
house for trick-or-treaters
it out follow me to the enchanted Garage
in every subsequent season the show
pulled out all the stops to celebrate
Halloween elaborate costumes hilarious
pranks and frightful Antics had viewers
tuning in to see who could outscare whom
Goodman reportedly joked that the
Connors were poor because they spent all
their money on Halloween even if the
Connors went broke celebrating the
season the amount of fun they had was
priceless
Roseanne Barr wrote for vulture that
When developing the show she needed
Roseanne to not just be funny but also
about the struggle to survive and
breaking taboos the show aired episodes
on domestic violence racism teen sex and
drugs but not without resistance Barr
fought with network sensors over several
issues including episodes about
menstruation and same-sex kissing the
season one episode Nightmare on Oak
Street made headlines for its
groundbreaking depiction of Sarah
Gilbert's Darlene experiencing her first
period Barr later told Oprah that the
episode met with resistance from ABC
saying it was hard because that had
never been on television later in the
show's run ABC alleged that the season 6
episode don't ask don't tell which
featured a kiss between Roseanne and
Mariel Hemingway's Sharon at a gay bar
violated Network standards and refused
to air the episode after bars demand
that the episode be shown it was
eventually released reportedly garnering
nearly 20 million views during its
Heyday Roseanne was one of the most
popular television shows in America so
it might come as a surprise that it was
virtually snubbed by TV's most
prestigious award the show was a
consistent hit for ABC and was
recognized by the New York Times in 1994
as the most watched entertainment show
in television over the past five years
despite its popularity Roseanne wasn't
nominated for a single Emmy Award for
outstanding comedy series during its 10
season run mom used to yell at us in the
shower it was like that scene in Psycho
take out the trash Roseanne Barr
lamented her initial lack of Emmy
recognition to the Los Angeles Times and
claimed it was likely retribution for
onset controversies Farr eventually won
an Emmy for Outstanding lead actress and
a comedy Series in 1993 with Goodman and
Laurie Metcalfe receiving multiple Emmys
for their work on the series while
Roseanne certainly earned its acting
accolades it can be baffling that the
show itself was never recognized in its
totality in 2017 the news broke that
most of Roseanne's original cast would
reprise their roles for a limited series
Revival on ABC even as the excitement
mounted there was the problem of how to
address the continuation of the series
after its season 9 finale well it's
television after all and Roseanne chose
to Simply ignore most of season 9's
finale in season 10's opener Dan is
still alive and other questions like who
exactly Darlene and Becky married were
left unanswered the first episode of the
Roseanne Revival pulled in over 18
million viewers the highest Network
comedy ratings in years in fact Roseanne
was 2018's most watched Series in total
viewers despite its popularity the
celebration was short-lived when ABC
canceled the series after Barr posted
racist comments on Twitter ABC
entertainment president Channing Dungey
stated Roseanne's Twitter statement is
abhorrent repugnant and inconsistent
with our values and we have decided to
cancel her show
Roseanne was a serious incubator for
up-and-coming Hollywood Talent with many
members of the show becoming some of
entertainment's most powerful players
Amy Sherman Palladino creator of Gilmore
Girls and the marvelous Mrs maisel super
producer Chuck Laurie and The Buffy the
Vampire Slayer Mastermind Joss Whedon
were all in the writer's room Judd
Apatow shared on tell me more with Kelly
Corrigan that supporting Barr with her
joke writing was his first big job and
even Norm Macdonald penned several
Roseanne episodes before his achieving
stardom on Saturday Night Live you know
the old man was almost a state champion
in high school were you ever in a cage
match only with your mom
although some might have forgotten
George Clooney on Roseanne he played
Jackie's love interest Booker Brooks in
the Show's first season before Clooney
became an oscar-winning movie star and
filmmaker he was just a working guy
sporting a pencil behind his ear while
audiences became acquainted with Johnny
Galecki as David on Roseanne he
eventually catapulted into Global Fame
on The Big Bang Theory Sarah Gilbert
parlayed her role as Darlene into a
successful producing career co-creating
the CBS chat show the talk she also
initiated and executive produced the
Roseanne Revival thank you
[Music]